Herkeslere selamlar. Ben Deniz Mehmet
hocanız. Arkadaşlar 9. sınıf tayfam.
Yepyeni bir konu, yepyeni bir başlık,
yepyeni bir sayfa açıyoruz. Yepyeni bir
temaya başlıyoruz. 5. tema algoritma
bileşim. Efendim tertemiz ettik.
Anlatılması gereken her şey ayrıntısıyla
çözülmesi gereken her soru tipini
göstererek, çözerek bitirdik. Şimdi
istatistiksel araştırma süreci
diyeceğiz. 6. tema diyeceğiz. 6. temayı
da seri halde birlikte götüreceğiz.
Burada ilk dersimiz biraz sözel olarak
başlıyor. Önce o nicel verilerden
bahsedeceğiz. Bunların temel
kavramlarından bahsedeceğiz. Burada
bilmemiz gereken bazı kavramlar var ki
sonrasındaki derslerde rahat edelim. Ama
ben sana hemen bunları göstereyim.
Elimizde kalemler, önümüzde tabii ki
matbook ders notları 9. sınıf ve diyoruz
ki hocam rehber matematik hocam
Instagram'dan takip ediyorsun değil mi?
Takip eden tayfa gerçekten kemik
tayfadır. Bunu unutma. Gönder gönder
gelsin dedim. Şimdi buradaki mevzuyu bir
göstermek istiyorum. Önce sana burada
temel kavramlardan bahsedeceğim. Dikkat
edersen istatiksel veri toplama süreci
ile ilgili, nicel veri toplama süreci
ile ilgili temel kavramlar. Bunlarla
ilgili sorular çözeceğiz. Bu dersi
bitireceğiz. Ama diyeceksin ki hocam
bizim okulda şunlar işleniyor. Merkezi
eğilim ölçüleri efendime söyleyeyim
aritmetik ortalama anlatılıyor. Bunlarla
ilgili efsane sorular hazırladım bu
arada sizler için. Ortanca medyan
değerleri anlatılıyor. Bunlarla ilgili
şeyler yapacağız mı? Yapacağız. Ama ne
zaman? İkinci dersi yapacağız. Şimdi bu
ders biraz böyle sözel havasına
geçeceğiz. Biraz böyle konuşacağız,
sohbet edeceğiz seninle. Temel
kavramları beraber öğrenmeye
çalışacağız. Ama elbette sorularım da
var tabii ki. Bu soruları da yine ne
yapacağız? Beraber çözeceğiz. Güzel
arkadaşım hazırsan başlayalım istersen.
Şimdi öncelikle temel kavramımız ne?
Neyi bilmemiz gerekiyor? Nicel veri ne
demek? Bunu çok iyi bilmen gerekiyor.
Çünkü sık sık sorularda karşımıza nicel
veri şeklinde gelecektir. Sayılarla
ifade elde edilebilen, ifade edilebilen,
ölçülebilen verilerdir. Örneğin
sınıftaki boyların uzunluğu, sınıftaki
matematik not değerleri, efendime
söyleyeyim kardeş sayısı herkesin.
Mesela yaşlar, çocukların yaşları,
ağırlıkları bunlar neler olabilir? Hop,
silgiyle yanlışlıkla sildik. Orayı
düzeltelim. Ağırlık, yaş, boy uzunluğu
bunlar nicel verilerdir. Bize burada
sayısal bazı değerler verecek. Geldim.
Bağlam ne demektir? Araştırmanın
yapıldığı, gerçek yaşam durumu yani
verilerin hangi ortamda neden
toplandığı, örneğin lise öğrencilerin
boy uzunlukları okul ortamında
topluyorsun. Doğru mu? Bunların boy
uzunluğuyla ilgili bazı verilerle ilgili
bazı sonuçlara varmak istiyorsun. İşte
buna bağlam deniyor. Geldim. Evren
araştırmanın sonuçlarını genellemek
istediği tüm topluluk anlamına geliyor.
Mesela mesela 9A'da, 9B'de ben bazı
veriler topladım. Boy uzunluğu olmasın
mesela, matematik notları olsun. Bunu
genelliyorum. Lise 9. sınıflarda bir
evren olarak kabul ediyorum. 9A'yı,
9B'yi ikisini birleştirdikten sonra.
Tamam mı? Evren dediğimde en geniş tanım
kümesi gibi düşünebilirsin. Oradaki en
geniş küme olarak düşünebilirsin. İşlem
yapılan en geniş küme gibi
düşünebilirsin. Değişken nedir? Gözlenen
özelliklerin bireyden bireye farklılık
göstermesi. Mesela buna neyi örnek
verebilirim? Her öğrencinin sınav notu
birbirinden farklı olabilir. Her
öğrencinin boy uzunluğu birbirinden
farklı olabilir. Bunlar değişkenliktir.
Değişkenlikle ilgili yeni bir başlık da
atacağım. Sonrasında burada bir
ayrıntıya gireceğiz. Geldim sorularda
sıkça karşıma gelecek olan en azından
sözel sorularda karşımıza gelecek olan
tek nicel değişken ne demektir? Bunun
tanımı önemli. Bir veri grubunda sadece
bir tane sayısal değişkenin olması
durumuna biz tek nicel değişken diyoruz.
Zaten nicel neydi? ölçülebilen
değişkendi. Tek deyince bir tane
anlamına geldi. Sadece boya uzunlukları
inceleniyorsa, sadece matematik notları
inceleniyorsa, sadece ellerindeki kalem
sayıları inceleniyorsa gibi ifadeler tek
nicel değişken anlamına gelecek. Az önce
de söyledim bak değişebilirlik önemli
bir şey. Yine bunu ayrı bir alt başlıkta
açacağım birazdan. Aynı gruptaki
değerlerin farklılık göstermesi durumu
değişebilirliktir. Örneğin herkesin notu
aynı olsaydı değişebilirlik olmazdı ama
her öğrencinin notu birbirinden farklı
olabilir. İşte biz bu duruma
değişebilirlik adını vereceğiz. Buraya
kadar galiba sıkıntı yoktur.
İstatistikler, istatiksel araştırma soru
türleri nelerdir? Hemen buna bakalım.
Hatta bununla ilgili bir tane örneğim
var. Şimdi betimleyici sorular.
Betimleyici soru ne demek? Bir gruba
tanımak, özelliklerini ortaya çıkarmak
veya analiz etmek amacıyla sorulan
sorulardır. Mesela bunu örnek ver hocam
dersen, sınıftaki öğrencilerin ortalama
boyu kaç santimdir diye sorduğumda
betimleyici bir soru sormuş olurum. O
gruba özel bir soru sormuş olurum. Ama
bir de ne var? Karşılaştıran soru
tipleri var. Bu da en az iki grup veya
değişken arasında fark olup olmadığını
öğreten, bize gösteren soru
modelleridir. Mesela erkek ve kız
öğrencilerin bu oy ortalamaları
arasındaki fark. Erkek ve kız
öğrencilerin efendime söyleyeyim not
ortalamaları arasındaki fark. Lise 9A 9B
sınıfındaki matematik ortalamaları ile
ilgili fark. Bak burada ne yapıyorum?
Karşılaştırmalı bir soru soruyorum. O
zaman iki tip sorumuz var. Biri
betimleyici soru. Bu genel gruba
yöneltilen soru. Teker teker cevaplar
alıyorsun. bir karşılaştırma söz konusu
değil. Bir de karşılaştıran soru
modelleri var. Kızlarla erkekler
olabilir. 9A ile 9B'nin bazı verileri
olabilir. Buna da karşılaştırma
tipindeki sorular diyorsun. Şimdi bak
hemen bir tane soru geliyor. Aşağıdaki
istatistiksel araştırma
sorularından betimleyici istatistiksel
araştırma sorusu olanların karşısına b
karşılaştıran istatiksel araştırma
sorusu olanların karşısına k yazın.
Betimleyici neydi? Sadece bir gruba özel
her birine aynı soruyu soruyorsun.
Diğerini de karşılaştırmaya
çalışıyorsun. Lise öğrencilerinin günlük
ortalama kitap okuma süresi kaç
dakikadır sorusu betimleyici bir
sorudur. Değil mi? Herkese özel olarak
bu soruyu soruyorsun. Sadece verileri
kendi arasında karşılaştırıyorsun. İki
grubu değil ya da daha fazla grubu
değil. Bak buradaki soru ne? Erkek ve
kız öğrencileri arasında günlük spor
yapma süreleri arasında fark var mıdır?
Burada karşılaştırmaya çalışıyorsun.
karşılaştıran istatiksel soru modelidir.
Bu farklı şehirlerde yaşayan bireylerin
aylık internet harcamaları. Farklı
şehirler. Birden fazla şehri
karşılaştırıyorsun. Vay bu aradaki fark
güzel. Bir okuldaki öğrencilerin
ortalama sınav puanından bahsettiğimde
betimleyici tarzda bir soru sormuş
oluyorum. Güzel. Bunu hallettik. Şimdi
gel burada da yine betimleyici ve
karşılaştırmacı soru tipine örnek bir
örneğimiz var. 5 kişilik bir öğrenci
grubundaki her öğrenciden kendilerine
verilen farklı durumlardan birer tane
tek nicel değişkenli veri toplamayı
gerektiren tek nicel değişken ne
demekti? Nicel sayısal veriler
ölçülebilir değerlerdi. Tek dediğinde
bir tane anlamına geliyordu. Toplamayı
gerektiren bir bağlam oluşturmaları
isteniyor. Aşağıdaki tabloda birinci
sütunda öğrencilere verilen gerçek yaşam
durumları, ikinci sütunda ise her
öğrencinin oluşturduğu bağlamlar karışık
şekilde verilmiştir. Buna göre tabloda
verilen yaşam durumlarına karşılık gelen
tek nicel değişkenli veri toplamayı
gerektiren bağlamları eşleştiriniz.
Şimdi bak sorudaki zorluğu malığı falan
bırakmayın kenara. Böyle bir dinlesem
bakayım arkadaş. Hocam birinci sayfada
sen bir sürü tanım verdin. Ben bunları
nasıl ezberleyeceğim falan diye. Onları
ezberlemiyorsun bize. Onlar soruların
içerisinde çıkıyor geliyor. Şimdi bak
teknel değişken bağlam kelimesi geçiyor.
Sen bunları bilirsen soruyu daha rahat
anlarsın. O yüzden o tanımları veriyoruz
en başta sınavda. Hayda getir bakalım
soru soralım. Genelde yapmaz hocalarımız
bunu. Seninki yapar onu. Ben bilmem.
Şimdi bu gerçekten kolay bir soru tarzı.
Gerçek yaşam durumu. Burada da tek nicel
değişkenli veri toplamayı gerektiren
bağlamlar. Mesela ulaşımla ilgili olan
biz burada ölçüm arıyoruz. Son 10 yılda
üniversite mezun sayısı ulaşımla mı
ilgili? Bir bölgede kişi başına düşen
yıllık elektrik tüketimi alakası yok.
Bir ülkede satılan bisiklet sayısı bak
ulaşımla ilgili. Bir platformda bir
yılda izlenen film sayısı geç. Bir
şehirde ortalama. Tamam bunu da geç. O
zaman sen 1i aslında kimle
eşleştiriyorsun? Eee ulaşımı buradaki
bisiklet sayısıyla eşleştirdim. Geçtim.
1i C ile eşleştirdim. Devam ettim.
Sağlıkla ilgili olana bakıyorum.
Üniversite sayısını geç. Kişi başı düşen
yıllık elektriği geç. İzlenen filmi geç.
Tabii ki su tüketimi sağlıkla ilgili
olabilir diyorum. 2'yi kimle
eşleştiriyorum? E ile eşleştirdim.
Geldim eğitimle ilgili olan tabii ki son
10 yılda üniversite mezun sayısı
olacaktır. 3'ü kimle eşleştirdim? A ile
eşleştirdim. Şuna da onayımı attım.
Enerji ile ilgili olan zaten bir tane
kaldı. Hop bu değil. İki tane kalmış.
Bir bölgede kişi başına düşen yıllık
elektrik tüketimi enerji ile alakalıdır.
4'ü B'ye götürdüm. Otomatikman eğlence
ile ilgili olan da filmle ilgili olan
cümleydi. Bunu da D'eile eşleştirdim.
Olay mevzu bu kadar. Bak buradaki
kavramlara, tanımlara benince rahat
ettim. Şimdi yine burayı açacağım. Sonra
deme hocam bir sayfayı yemin ediyorum
ezberletiyorsun bize ya. Vallahi bak bir
ezber falan vermeye çalıştım. Yok
buradaki mantığı sana göstermeye
çalışıyorum. Buradaki kavramları
öğretmeye çalışıyorum kolay kolay.
Matematikte bu tarz soru ben de yazmam,
sormam açıkçası ama okuldaki hocana da
bağlı onu da söyleyeyim. Ha bazı
okullarda buraları işlenmemiş bile.
Yazık gün ya bunlar anlatılmaz mı abi?
Map kitabında var. İyi bir araştırma
konusunda bulunması gereken sekiz tane
özellik olmalıdır. Ezberleme bunları.
Sadece böyle kulak doygunluğu olsun. Bir
amaç net olmalıdır. Ne demek bu? Soru
betimleyici mi? Soru net anlaşılıyor mu
yoksa karşılaştırıcı mı? Bunu bilmemiz
gerekiyor. Ne tarz bir soru geliyor?
araştırmaya değer olmalıdır. Anlamlı
sonuçlar ve işe yarar sonuçlar
gelmelidir. Evet, boy uzunluğuna
baktığımızda anlamlı sonuçlardır ama göz
rengi onun sonucunda nereye varmak
istiyorsun? Hani çok anlamlı bir şey
çıkmıyorsa anlamlı sonuçlar vermeli.
Araştırmaya değer olmalı. İlgilenilen
grup evren. Ki ilgilenen gruba biz ne
demiştik? İşlem yapılan en büyük
topluluğa evren adını vermiştik.
İlgilenilen grup açık olmalı. kimin
hakkında sorusuna net cevap vermeli.
Hatta bununla ilgili birazdan soru da
var. Sona doğru dersin. Dersin. Değişken
açıkça görülmeli. Ne hakkında veri
toplanıyor? Hani boy uzunluğu mu, ders
notu mu? Değişken net gözükmeli.
Değişebilirliği veri toplanarak
cevaplanabilmeli. Özür dilerim burada 5.
maddeyi atlıyorduk. Veri toplanarak
cevaplanabilmeli. Soru birincil ya da
ikincil verilerle ölçülebilir olmalı.
Değişebilirliği olmalı. Şimdi
değişebilirliği biliyorsun. Boy uzunluğu
kişiden kişiye değişebiliyordu. Cevaplar
kişiden kişiye farklılık göstermeli.
Değişebilirlik şu durumlardan
kaynaklanabilir. Şimdi bununla ilgili
güzel bir sorum var. O yüzden bunu
özellikle üstüne basarak söylüyorum.
Hatta önemli olanları istersen senin
için şöyle bak burayı işaretleyeyim.
değişebilirlik şu durumlardan kaynaklı
olabilir. Doğal ortam durumundan
kaynaklı değişebilirlik olabilir.
Örneğin bir deney yapılıyordur. Oradaki
bakteri sayısına bakılıyordur. Ama
oradaki doğal ortam işte oksijen ortamı,
güneş ışığını alma durumu. Bu neyi
etkiler? O deneyin sonucunda elde
edilecek verileri etkiler. Biz buna
doğal ortamdan kaynaklı değişebilirlik
diyoruz. Örneğin A şehrinde ya da yan
yana iki tane bile denesen veri ölçmeye
çalışsan ikisinin aldığı güneş enerjisi
bir değildir bir şey değildir. Doğal
ortamdan kaynaklı değişebilirlik olur.
Ölçüm kaynıyla da değişebilirlik
olabilir. Örneğin eskiden hani böyle
metra yoktu ya eee böyle arşın dediğimiz
mevzuyla şöyle ölçüm yapardık işte bir
arşın, iki arşın, 3 arşın ama herkesin
arşını farklı olduğu için ne olur? Ölçüm
kaynaklı değişebilirlik elde edilebilir.
Müdahale kaynaklı değişebilirlik
olabilir. Örneğin bir iki öğrenci
grubundaki performansı değerlendirmek
istiyorsun ama birine ekstra özel ders
veriyorsun. Haliyle ne oluyor? Müdahale
kaynaklı diğerinin daha yüksek çıkması
olabilir. Örneklem kaynaklı
değişebilirlik olabilir. Örnekler
birbirinden farklıysa haliyle onların da
verecebildiği değişebilirlik de
birbirinden farklı olabilir. Çok
takılma. Sadece bu cümleleri, bu
örnekleri görmende fayda var.
odaklanılan grup analiz yapılmasına
uygun olmalıdır. Tek tek bireyleri değil
grubun eğilimini ölçmelidir. Örnek en
uzun kim değil, boy ortalaması nedir
gibi ölçümler yapmalıdır. Nicel veri
toplamaya uygun olmalıdır. Veriler
sayılabilir veya ölçülebilir olmalıdır.
Örneğin boy uzunluğu ölçülebilir veri
oluyor ya. Demek ki bu 8 madde ne
yapılmalı? tek nicel değişkenli veri
toplamayı gerektiren araştırma sorusu
olabilmesi için bu 8 özelliği sağlamalı.
Şimdi geldim burada tekrar şuraya
değinmekte fayda var. Betimleyici
sorular bir grubun özelliğini inceler.
Büyükşehirlerde yaşayan bireylerin toplu
taşıma kullanma sıklıkları nelerdir? Bu
betimleyici bir sorudur. Ama
karşılaştırıcı soru neydi? İki veya daha
fazla grubun verilerini farklı olup
olmadığını inceliyordu. Kadınlar ve
erkekler arasında stres yönetimi
becerileri nasıl farklılık gösterilir?
Bu karşılaştırıcı soru. Bu betimleyici
soru oluyordu. Anlaştık mı? Şimdi az
önce anlattığım o süreçle ilgili ne
yapacağız? Örnek bir soru çözeceğim ama
çözümü de veriyorum ki maksat buradaki
mantığı görmen. Şimdi Milli Eğitim
Bakanlığı öğrenci barışı arısını
etkileyen faktörleri belirlemek amacıyla
ülke genelinde bir araştırma başlatıyor.
Bu araştırma kapsamında okullarda
öğrencilerin günlük ders çalışma
süreleri, öğretmen beklentileri, okul
imkanları gibi çeşitli konularda veri
toplanıyor. Bu araştırma doğrultusunda
yapılan uygulamalarda birinde de bir
ilçedeki ortaokul öğrencilerine günlük
ne kadar süre ders çalıştıklarının
sorulması.
Araştırma sorusu aşağıdaki gibiymiş.
Günde ortalama kaç saat ders
çalışıyorsunuz? Tamam mı? Buna göre
oluşturulan soruyu istatiksel araştırma
sorusunda bulunması gereken ölçütlere
göre inceleyiniz. He şimdi o ölçütler
nelerdi? Bir amaç açık mı? Şimdi amaç
açık neden? Öğrencinin günlük ders
çalışma süresini betimlemeye yönelik bir
amaç var burada. yukarısıyla
karşılaştırıyor. Aslında bu cevapları
vermesem de beraber yorumlayabiliriz ama
bunlar tek başına kolay kolay bir soru
olarak gelmez. Maksat buradaki mantığı
yakalan. Araştırmaya değer mi? Tabii ki
değer. Öğrencilerin ders çalışma
süresiyle başarının ilişkisini ölçmeye
çalışıyor. Onu anlamlandırmaya
çalışıyor. İlgilenilen grup yani evren
açıkça belirtilmiş mi? Kısmen
belirtilmiş. Yani ortaokul öğrencileri
demiş ama sınıf grubu ya da okul adı
verilmemiş. Ama daha açık belirtilse
daha güzel olurdu tabii. Değişken açıkça
görülüyor mu? Evet, değişken ders
çalışma süresi açıkça belirtilmiş. Veri
toplanarak cevaplanabilir mi? Evet.
Öğrencilere sorularak birincil ne
yapılabilir? Veriye çevrilebilir. Dersin
ki öğrenciye sen kaç saat çalışıyorsun?
Sen kaç saat çalışıyorsun? Sen kaç saat
çalışıyorsun? Veriler toplanarak
cevaplanabilir. Değişebilirlik var mı?
Elbette var. Öğrenciden öğrenciye
bunların çalıştığı ortamlara göre ne
olacaktır? Sürelerde değişebilirlik
gözlenecektir. Her öğrenci aynı saat
çalışıyor demezsin sonuçta. Odaklanılan
grup analiz yapılmasına uygun mu? Evet.
Birey birey değil grup genelinde çalışma
sürelerinin dağılımı analiz edilebilir.
Nicel veriyi toplamaya uygun mu? Tabii
ki saat cinsinden ölçülebilir bir
veriden bahsediyoruz. Çalışma süresinden
bahsediyoruz. Şimdi demek ki böyle bir
soru gelirse bu şekilde basitçe ne
yapılabilir?
cevaplanabilir. Şimdi çok üzerinde
durmaya başladık. Burayla ilgili biraz
daha üzerinde duracağız. Hatta bunun
üstüne ben dör tane de örnek çözeceğim
sana. Değişebilirlik mevzusu dedik ya.
Veri grubundaki elemanların her birinden
farklı veriler alınabilir. Bu da
değişebilirliği sağlar. Değişebilirlik
istatiksel araştırmada verilerin kişiden
kişiye veya durumdan duruma farklılık
göstermesi. Bu farklılıklar araştırma
sonuçlarının yorumlanmasını ve anlam
kazanmasını sağlar. Değişebilirlik
araştırma sürecinin doğal bir
parçasıdır. Şimdi değişebilirlik dört
tür de olabilir. Birincisi bunlar
önemli. Doğal ortamdan kaynaklı
değişebilirlik olabilir. Farklı veriler
elde edilebilirsin ortamdan kaynaklı.
Bireylerin içinde bulunduğu çevresel
koşullardan dolayı veriler değişebilir.
İklim, yaşanılan bölge, beslenme
alışkanlığı. Bunlar farklı veriler elde
etmene sebep olur. İkincisi ölçümden
kaynaklı değişebilirlik olabilir. Farklı
bir araç kullanılabilir. Farklı bir
ölçme aracı kullanılabilir. Ya da
kişilere yapılan ölçümler birbirinden
farklı sonuçlar verebilir. Güzel. Farklı
terazilerle yapılan ölçümler haliyle
farklı sonuçlar verebilir. Bu kimden
kaynaklı değişebilirliktir? Ölçümden
kaynaklı. Örneğin ben 1 kilo pamuk
tartacağım. Pamuk tartıyoruz. Yalnız 5
tane farklı tartı çeşidim var ama farklı
çeşitleri farklı sonuçlar verebilirler
değil mi? Orta tartının güvenilirliği
ile de alakalı bir durum var gerçi. 3.
Müdahaleden kaynaklı değişebilirlik
olabilir. Deneysel araştırma grubunda
örneğin bazı grup iki öğrenci grubu
aldığımızı düşün. A ve B öğrenci grubu.
A grubu normal çalışarak sınava giriyor.
B grubu özel ders alarak ya da
YouTube'da rehber matematik dinleyerek
giriyor. Şimdi müdahale var burada.
YouTube rehber matematik müdahalesi var.
büyükçe bir oranla sınavdan yüksek
alması lazım o adamın. Şimdi öyle değil
mi? Bir gruba verilen eğitim sonrası
başarı durumu ne olabilir? Müdahaleden
kaynaklı değişebilir diğer gruba göre.
Şimdi geldim 4te örneklemden kaynaklı
değişebilirlik. Farklı bireylerden
oluşan gruplarda ne yapılabilir? farklı
değişkenlikler, değişiklikler alınması
normaldir. Farklı sınıflarda sınav
ortalamalarının farklı olması
örneklemden kaynaklıdır. Farklı sınıflar
üzerinde çalışıyoruz çünkü aynı sınıfta
1. matematik sınavı, 2. sını matematik
sınavından bahsetmiyoruz. Şimdi sorusu
nasıl olabilir? Bir biyoloji öğretmeni
okulun laboratuvarında yer alan bir suda
bulunan oksijen miktarını ha 6 hafta
boyunca ölçümlendiriyor. Öğretmen bu
süre zarfında suya hiçbir dış müdahalede
bulunmuyor. Elde edilen veriler tabloda
veriliyor. Ölçümler bunlar da haftalar.
7,2, 6,8, 7,5 6,9, 7,1, 7,4. Bu durumda
diş müdahale olmamasına rağmen ölçüm
sonuçlarında farklılık gözmesinin sebebi
ne tür bir değişebilirliği ortaya
çıkarır? Ortaya koyar. Bunu açıklayın
diyor. Şimdi şimdi değişebilirlik
türleri kaç taneydi? 4 taneydi. Bir
doğal ortamdan kaynaklı, iki ölçümden
kaynaklı, müdahaleden kaynaklı,
örneklemden kaynaklı hiçbir diş
müdahalede olmadığından bahsediyor. Aynı
ölçü grubunu kullanıyorsun. Aynı
elemanları kullanıyorsun. O zaman bu
verilerin farklı çıkmasının sebebi ne
olabilir? İşte güneş ışığını aldığı
pozisyondan olabilir. Ortamdaki nemden
farklı olabilir. O zaman bu
değişebilirliğin tek sebebi ne olabilir
arkadaş? Doğal ortamdan kaynaklı
olabilir. Doğal ortamdan kaynaklı
değişebilirlik. Kaynaklı
kaynaklı değişebilirlik.
[Müzik]
Değişebilirlik. Güzel. Sebebi ne
olabilir dedik. Güneş ışının yansıması
olabilir, gelmesi olabilir. Ortamdaki
nemin değişmesi olabilir. Bu ortamdan
kaynaklı bir değişebilirlik sonucunda
farklı veriler elde edildi diyebilirim.
Hemen geldim diğerine. Bir okulda
öğrencilerin sınav başarısını arttırmak
amacıyla 2 hafta boyunca belirli bir
sınav sınafa her gün 20 dakikalık ekstra
matematik etütü çalışması uygulanıyor.
Aynı sınıftaki öğrencilerin etüt öncesi
ve sonrası yapılan sınavlarda aldıkları
ortalama puanlar aşağıda veriliyor.
Şimdi etüt öncesinde 58 alıyormuş
öğrenciler. Etüt sonrası 51 alıyor.
Demek ki dışarıdan bir müdahale
yaptığımda yani etüt verdiğimde ne
yapıyorum? Sınav sonucuna etki
edebiliyorum. değişebilirlik sağlıyorum.
Ortalamada okul yönetimi bu sonuçları
incelediğinde öğrencilerin başarı
düzeyinin arttığını gözlemliyor. Bu
farkın nedenini nasıl açıklarsın? Bu
farkın nedeni nedir? Dikkat edersen
müdahale yapılıyor, değil mi? Bir
müdahale var. O zaman buradaki
farklılığın sebebi kesinlikle nedir?
Müdaha
haleden kaynaklı kaynaklı değişebilirlik
değişebilirlik gözlemleniyor. Ne
yapılıyor? Dışarıdan bir müdahale
yapılıyor. Ekstra etüt dersi veriliyor
gibi. Bu kadar çok kolay. Bak düşündüğün
kadar zor değil ha. Bir sonraki dersten
itibaren affetmem yalnız ha. Aritmetik
ortalama bakacağız, medyan bakacağız.
Öyle herkesin çözdüğü standart örnekleri
çözmeyeceğiz. ÖSYM tipi sorular
çözeceğiz. Derece tayfa soruları
çözeceğiz. RM, rehber matematiğe yakışan
soruları orada çözeceğiz. Anlaştık mı?
Gel bakayım. Şimdi 6. sorudayız. Bir
öğretmen aynı sınıf düzeyinde iki farklı
şubede yer alan öğrencilerin günlük
kitap okuma sürelerini karşılaştırmak
istiyor. Her iki şubede de 10 öğrenciye
bir günde ortalama kaç dakika kitap
okuyorsunuz diye sorusu yöneltiyor.
Cevaplar kaydediliyor. Aşağıdaki tabloda
iki şubeye ait öğrencilerin ortalama
okuma süreleri veriliyor. A şubesi 38
dakika, B şubesi 52 dakika ortalama
kitap okuyor. Öğrenciler aynı okulda,
aynı sınıf düzeyinde eğitim alıyor
olmalarına rağmen kitap okuma
sürelerinin neden farklı olduğu
soruluyor. Şimdi bu kitap okuma süresi
neyden farklı olabilir? Bir kere bu
öğrenci gruplarının aile grupları
birbirinden farklıdır. A'daki ile B'deki
aile grupları birbirinden farklı
olabilir. Öğrencilerin alışkanlıkları
farklı olabilir. Sınıflar aynı, okul
düzeyi aynı, her şey aynı olabilir ama
gelen öğretmenler farklı olabilir.
Öğretmenlerin kazandırdığı alışkanlıklar
farklı olabilir. Sonuçta biz iki tane
farklı örneklem grubu üzerinde
çalışıyoruz. O zaman örneklemden
kaynaklı bir farklılık yaşayabilirim ben
burada, değil mi? O halde yazıyorum. Ne
yazıyorum? Örneklemden kaynaklı.
Örneklemden kaynaklı. Kaynaklı.
Değişiklik değil mi? Değişiklik. Güzel.
Bunun da mantığını gördük. Bak dör tane
vardı. Doğal ortamdan kaynaklı, ölçümden
kaynaklı, müdahaleden kaynaklı,
örneklemden kaynaklı. Şimdi doğal
ortamla ilgili sorumuzu çözdük zaten.
Müdahale ile ilgili olanı çözdük.
Örneklemden kaynaklı olanı çözdük. acaba
ölçmden ölçümden kaynaklı
değişebilirlikle ilgili örneğin var mı
dersen aslında bu ona örnek ama sebebini
görelim. Ben hepsine birer örnek yapıp
sana en azından buradaki mantığı
gösteriyorum. Bir ya tane örnek yapar
geçelim ama abi gönlüm el vermez benim
öğrencim benim. RM her şeyi görmüş
olsun. Biz o örnekten de çözdük. Biz bu
örnekten de çöz hocam biz hepsinden
çözdük ya. Bir öğretmen evinden okula
yürüyerek geliyor. Yerel bir okul ile
şehir arasındaki okul arasındaki
mesafeyi ölçmek için öğrencilerin 6 gün
boyunca yaptığı ölçümlere kendi
adımlarıyla 4 gün boyunca
karşılaştırılmak isteniyor. Aşağıdaki
tabloda Zeynep'in yaptığı ölçümler
veriliyor. 1ci 6 güne kadar ölçtüğü
ölçümler bunlar. Yol aynı. Ya bir dakika
eee Zeynep her ölçümde evi ile okulu
arasındaki mesafeyi neden farklı buluyor
ya? Adım uzunlukları birbirinden farklı
olduğu için. E bu hangi değişebilirliğe
örnek? Ölçümden kaynaklı değişebilirliğe
örnektir. Ölçüm aracının boyu değişiyor
sürekli. Adım boyu değişiyor. Ölçümden
kaynaklı.
Ölçümden kaynaklı değişebilirlik.
Kaynaklı değişebilirlik
[Müzik]
değişebilirlik. Güzel. Bunu da
öğrendiğimize göre. Hadi gel bakalım.
Şimdi nicel veri toplama planı ile
ilgili sana anlatacaklarım var. Burada 7
tane madde var. Ondan sonra 5 tane de
test sorum var. Bu dersi bitireceğiz
hızlıca. Ben sana aritmetik ortalama
medyanla ilgili derse göndereceğim.
Orayla da ilgili. Şimdi bazı arkadaşlar
yazıyor hocam okulda biz bayağı
ilerledik. Hiç panik yok abi. Top bizde.
Biz o işi halledeceğiz beraber.
Araştırmacılar istatistiksel araştırma
sorularını cevaplandırabilmek için veri
toplama planı yapmalıdır. Bu plan
aşağıdaki adımları içerir. Bir uygun
veri toplama aracı belirlenmelidir.
Soruya cevap verecek. Veri birincil yani
doğrudan toplanan ya da ikincil yani
hazır kaynaklardan alınabilir. İki
şekilde alınabilir. Araç soruya uygun
seçilmelidir. Şimdi boy uzunluğunu
hesaplayacaksın. Adama metre vermezsen
nasıl hesaplayacaksın? Uygun veri
toplama aracı belirlenmeli. Santim
cinsinden mesela değil mi? Evren ve
örneklem örneklem tanımlanmalıdır. Evren
dediğimiz neydi? İşlem yapılacak en
büyük küme tanımlanmalı. Lise
öğrencilerinde mi? Ortaokul
öğrencilerinde mi yoksa mezun gruplarda
mı ya da anne babalarda mı, kızlarda mı,
erkeklerde mi değil mi? Bu evren
belirlenmeli. Tüm bireyler yani evren
belirlenmeli. Bu evreni temsil edecek
grup mantıklı ve ölçülebilir şekilde
seçilmeli. Rastgelel sağlanmalı.
örneklem seçilirken her bireyin eşit
şansa sahip olması gerekebilir. Bu
güvenilirliği arttırır. Şimdi sen bir
veri grubunda efendime söyleyeyim neyi
ölçeceksin? Matematik notlarını
ölçeceksin. Bir grup hiç rehber
matematik izlememiş. Bu grup her gün
izliyor. Haliyle rastgelelik sağlanmaz.
Bir güvenilirlik sağlanmaz. O grubun
rehber RMA'nın oradaki matematik
noktada bir torpil var gibi olur. İşte o
yüzden rastgele olmalı. Rastgele
seçilmeli grup. Değişkenler
belirlenmeli. Araştırmada ölçülecek veya
etki edecek faktörler net şekilde
ayarlanmalı. Veri toplama süreci
belirlenmeli. Veriler nereden, ne zaman,
nasıl, kimin tarafından toplanacak, yüz
yüze mi, çevrim içi mi alınacak? Bu
detaylar planlanmalı. Verilerin kaydı
nasıl olacak? Bu önceden ayarlanmalı.
Hangi araçlarla nasıl kayıt altına
alınacağı net olmalı. Örneğin dijital
platformda mı, kağıtta mı, ses kaydında
mı, video kaydında mı bunlar önemli.
Gizlilik ve dürüstlük esas alınmalı.
Kişisel veriler korunmalı. Etik dışı
davranışlardan kaçınılmalı. Araştırmacı
sonuçlar değiştirmemeli. Beklentisine
göre, araştırmacının beklentisine göre
de bir yönlendirme
yapılmamalıdır. Şimdi gel oradaki
verileri de böyle güzelce hallettikten
sonra burayla ilgili gelebilecek test
soruları nelerdir hocam? Bir gösterir
misin dersen hızlıca bakalım. Bir veri
grubunun özelliklerinin. Hatta burası
artık bizim ne? Yeşil sayfamız. Yeşil
sayfaların mantığını biliyorsun. Soru
avcısı. Bir kitaptan belki daha fazla
soru bankasından daha fazla soruyu
çözüyoruz. Bir grubun özelliklerinin
sayılması veya ölçülmesi ile elde edilen
verilere nokta nokta veriler denir. Buna
göre yukarıdaki cümlede boş bırakılan
yerlere gelmesi gereken uygun ifade
aşağıdakilerden hangisidir? Bir veri
grubunun özelliklerinin sayılması,
ölçülmesi, ölçülme ile ilgili olan
başlığımız neydi? Nicel verilerdi, değil
mi? Nicel veri denir buna. Doğru cevap E
seçeneği. Hemen geldim ikincisine.
Yukarıda anket çalışmasından toplanan
verilerden hangileri nicel ölçülebilir
bir veridir? Son 10 yılda Türkiye'de eee
metrekareye düşen ağaç sayısının
değişimine ilişkin toplanan veriler.
Ölçülebilen bir veridir. Nicel veridir.
Onayladım. Bireylerin harcadıkları
günlük kalori miktarlarına ilişkin
toplanan veriler. Tabii ki ölçülebilir.
Kalori değil mi? Ölçülebilir bir
veridir. Devam ettim. Kişilerin
kullandığı diş fırçasını ilk olarak
nerede gördüklerine ilişkin toplanan
veriler. Tabii ki bu da yine ölçülebilen
değildir. Oğlum ne alaka? Gördüğün yerle
benim ölçülebilecek bir şeyim var mı?
Markette mi gördün? Arkadaşında mı
gördün? Reklamda mı gördün? Infiloer'da
mı gördün? Nerede? Ya bu ölçülebilir bir
şey değil. O yüzden 1 ve 2 ölçülebilir
değerlerdir. Geldim 3. soruma.
Yukarıdaki durumlardan hangileri nicel
veri olarak değerlendirilebilir? Yine
benzer tipte bir soru. Öğrencilerin boy
uzunluklarının ölçülmesi. Tabii ki boy
uzunluğu diyorsan ölçülebiliyor zaten.
Bir fabrikanın günlük elektrik
tüketiminin kaydedilmesi. Tabii ki bu da
nicel bir veri. Elektrik tüketimi nicel
veridir. İnsanların kitap oluma, okuma
alışkanlık. Alışkanlık bir ölçülebilir
bir şey değildir. Bunu ölçemezsin, değil
mi? Doğru cevap burada ne olacaktır? B
seçeneği
olacaktır. Aşağıdakilerden hangisi nicel
veriye
dayalı istatistiksel araştırma
ölçütlerine uygun değildir? Neye uygun
değilmiş? Nicel veriye dayalı. Bakalım.
İstatistiksel araştırma sorularında amaç
net olarak görülmelidir. Evet, net
olmalıdır amaç araştırmaya değer bir şey
olmalıdır. Soru kimin hakkında sorusunun
cevabı araştırma sorusunda görülmelidir.
Neyin hakkında? Kimin hakkında biz
araştırma yapıyoruz? Değil mi? Bu
görülmeli. Sorular hangi veriler
hakkında sorusunun cevabı araştırma
sorusunda görülmelidir. Hangi veriler
hakkında biz bilgi toplamaya
çalışıyoruz? Bu da önemli.
Değişebilirliği yansıtmamalıdır. Olur mu
lan? Asıl değişebilirliği yansıtmadı.
Değişebilir olsun ki verileri
değerlendirebileyim. Yoksa herkesin boyu
1.60. Abi ben nesini değerlendireyim
bunun değil mi? Değişebilir olmalı. Gel.
Mantıklı şeyi işaretliyorsun zaten.
Aşağıdaki tanımlardan hangisi yanlıştır?
Gözlenen elemanların bir özelliğine ait
yalnızca bir nicel veri toplanıyorsa bu
veri türüne tek nicel değişkenli denir.
Bingo zaten tek nicel değişkenlinin
tanımıdır bu aynı zamanda. Gel.
Araştırmanın kapsamına alınan bireylerin
tümüne evren denir. En geniş çalıştığım
kitleye evren deniyordu. Doğru.
Araştırma sorularına cevap bulmak
amacıyla doğrudan toplanan verilere
ikincil veri denir. Bir dakika. İkincil
veri nerelerden alınan verilerdi?
Kaynaklardan toplanandı. Biz direkt
araştırma grubundan alıyorsak bu veriyi
birincil veriydi bu. Bir beklesin
bakayım. Hatalı değil mi? Veriler farklı
kişilerden farklı şekillerde toplanır.
Bu durum değişebilirliği açıklar. Bravo.
Farklı kişilerden alıyorsun. Farklı
durumlardan alıyorsun. Bir grubun
özelliklerinin ölçülmesiyle elde edilen
veriler nicel veri olarak adlandırılır.
Ölçme varsa nicel veri vardır. O zaman
yanlış olan hangisidir? İkincil veri
diyen C seçeneğidir. Doğru cevabımız C
dedik. Misler gibi istatistiksel
araştırma sürecinin yani 6. temanın
temel kavramlarını baz aldığımız
dersimiz sona ermiştir. Ama hemen ben
hazırlıyorum ikinci ders için. Hemen
şöyle biraz dinleneceğim. Ardından hemen
ikinci videoyu patlatacağım. Burada neyi
anlatacağım sana? merkezi eğilim
ölçülerinden olan aritmetik ortalamadan
ve ortancadan yani medyandan
bahsedeceğim. Bunlarla ilgili inanılmaz
lezzetli kaliteli sorularım var. Bunları
beraber çözeceğiz. Olayı bitireceğiz.
Haydi bakalım RM tayfa. Beğenmeyi
unutmuyorsun. Yorum atmayı asla
unutmuyorsun. Instagram'dan takip
etmeyen tayfaya da vallahi kırılırım
burada. Instagram'da takip et. Güçlü
olalım. Beraber olalım. Gerçekten 9'dan
12'ye kadar beraber gidelim. Hadi
bakalım. Kendine iyi bak. Hoş kal. Hoşça
kal.
H